what is happening there citizens of the reject
Nation rejoined by Aaron Alexander how you doing
buddy it's been a long time it's been a spell
I am doing good I'm excited to be back happy to
have you here because what are we watching today
buddy we're watching Invincible Adam Eve this is
a prequel episode is it season two or is it to
the season one it's in but in between is it in
between her yeah like uh like black widow all
right good Aaron I did not re-watch Invincible
I mean you catch our reactions to it but we are
planning less I'm planner you plan on planning on
rewatching it before season two comes out oh yeah
officially yeah even though Amazon listed says
season two episode one yeah we haven't watched
that in like two years but uh I've got a little
bit of a memory here so guys with that in mind
smash that like button haven't said smashed in
such a long time also be sure to subscribe and
click that notification Bell to get notified in
a few months when we cover Invincible season
two properly you excited Aaron hella excited
let's swerve from the path of our regular content
to delve into a realm where Shadow fights light
mythical Champions become the architects of
their own destiny yes you've called it rage
Shadow Legends it's more than just a name it's
an invitation to a symphony of battles that would
make even a dragon trip in the mystical expanse
of Talaria Darkness looms under the veil reign of
the dark lord siroth Only You Brave Summoner can
conjure an alliance of Champions to Vanquish this
malevolent force a world teeming with dungeons
formidable adversaries and breathtaking Landscapes
is yearning for a hero from a legion of over 700
unique Champions across diverse factions you can
craft an army as unique as a phoenix feather
shape them into an unbeatable force that will
make even the stone golems envious outfit them
with potential artifacts imbue them with Untold
power and let them unleash their full potential
test your steal against other heroes in the PVP
Arena Battle the great leviathans of the game
World the send the clan rankings and become the
beacon of Glory in the gloaming The Saga raid is
ever evolving witnessed care of the new Phantom
General akamori whose might overshadows even
the diarist of nightmares also if the animated
series raid called The Arbiter Escape your
gaze the complete 10 episodes away to an
official rage Shadow Legends YouTube channel
so are you ready to seize a sword of Destiny
and dive into the heart of Rage Shadow Legends to
some of my QR code or conjure up the link in the
description box to initiate your quest an epic
Champion Drake of the Lizardman faction along
with a horde of other Treasures awaits you let's
weave our Legends together so don't forget light
the way by hitting my link in the description box
or the QR code on screen and I'll see you in the
Twilight of the battlefield as the Arbiter
watches over us may you always find Victor
oh man we saw the first season oh my God
on a little computer monitor remember that
we've come so far we're fighting conquer
we'll find this room faster if we split
up no my son that's not a tactically sound
strategy one of those lizard people we need
to stay together what Mom Prince lizard just
straightforward name yeah our intel was spotty
but the serum should be on this level the
Flames of this Burning world will warm are
cold blood onward until the lizard leave oh
boy the lizard League love the alliteration
the Guardians the Guardians of the globe
oh so this is like an actual prequel this
is a prequel yeah this doesn't have
to get any uglier than it already
is it's like they're taking the serpent
Society is that what they're doing here
sure about that God I did miss
the show I was just thinking
the same thing this reminds me of the the
season premiere though except in reverse
you better you better than hire goal is
that black Samsung don't waste your time
Samson oh it is Darkwing not coming down still
healing after the corona dial Battle Red Rush
busy in Russia and Martian man's helping dark
blood on some important Mission dark blood was
that the the demon guy yeah nice this feels so
much like a DC animated movie oh yeah totally
do they live I don't know oh Omni man Big Daddy
stash new suit yeah the tailor said it wasn't
iconic enough apparently everyone's running around
with a big letter on their chest these days he's
looking at me and you won't do for two more weeks
I'm sorry Dr brandyworth I know how important this
baby is oh is that Adam Eve I should have found
another one [__] some kind of telepath aren't
you yeah oh they're getting closer we have to get
you to a hospital yeah this has to be years before
I took it because yeah uh Samson has bald head
in the present she was literally born like pretty
much on the battlefield of the Guardians wow yeah
so sorry I did this to you feels like The Stranger
Things scientists totally yeah papa we're headed
for the Valley Hospital a child is too valuable
to leave her birthday we have a hospital I just
realized we don't see her mom in the show bring up
bring up you'll get your weapon and in
the end you'll thank me for it classic
that voice on the phone sounds so familiar who
is that I don't know also You Gotta Throw your
phone out the window sits at the media
staple you must be ready for any other
now it's probably worth more
protection you know like
you really cared about her look cut it out cut it
up section C-section C-section let's go
let's go see that [__] cut that belly
find me the buddies oh maybe this special
is about him trying to find her again oh
like stranger things like Papa yeah
Mr and Mrs Wilkins you want this one who thought
she was gone but take it she came back to us ah
switcheroo Sam sure loves her Legos huh it's
the only thing she'll play with good Easter
egg any idea why Mercury is a liquid at room
temperature when it's surrounded by solids my
they got a bond Robert Oppenheimer Killian Murphy
Sam's been making molecules for me check it out
that's baking soda this one is glucose and believe
it or not that's magnesium I'll punch this guy
oh science in my goddamn house she
could barely read it all she has these
molecules memorized like she could just
see them in her head get out of my house
he's 16. for all we know he made it all up if he
was a white kid I would take this news differently
that's the last time we
let it colored in the house
grossy now concentrate on maintaining your form is
that just like his muscle fibers oh yeah I don't
like it is that what's his name oh Jesus is that
the little baby guy the the robot oh maybe hi I'm
Samantha Wilkins right I guess you know I'm the
weirdo that lives across the street from you oh
wait you're just smart girl that's what my mom
said I'm bow the even weirder weirdo who lives
across the street from you it's about part
of the Teen Titans group she was a part of I
don't think so you've got homework to do if you
want to get your grades up my grades are great
your mother and I were told you were special
how silly us we thought that meant you should
go to a school for special kids why is this guy
like the biggest [__] in the world they don't
have any fun or care about anything they're
just a bunch of freaks they're freaks look
at yourself isn't that why you belong there
ouch damn dad what is your problem she knows
like I don't know I don't know man you've been
a dick this whole episode you kind of meant that
here it is
yeah science
science [__]
she's like seeing things on a
molecular level oh turn to class
wow that's cool sell them at an art museum
make money change back change back change
that's cool it's kind of broken kind of a op
power if you ask me I made you a snack sweetie
cream cheese and Olive sandwich what
you had that [__] that [__] no
don't play with your food that's what I'm
talking about so I'm talking about Adam
Eve keep playing with your food never stop
spearmint right now it's Cherry try it oh no
she reacted to her powers very well right
Sam I'm serious how are you doing this she is
not reacting to her friend's Powers very well
not taking it wow I can
make stuff I've heard stuff
thought it was fun it's not okay
it's freaking scary you're a freak
I should go home now wait big ass friend Val
oh that's your one and only friend
he's my friend I said let's make some weird
[__] yeah man dude if you give me superpowers
I'd be jealous let's drink all the ginger
ale we want to be like get me some G fuel
oh pink it's your favorite color thing is pink
like her outfit remember to write a thank you note
to Aunt Penny is that Anne penny Penn Easter
egg that'll be totally missed I don't know
better fits let's go do not hurt that
animal make it a Super Squirrel I wish
you were a puppy make it talk I wish I had a puppy
she makes a puppy out of thin air
oh dude you're you've become a
homeless man yo yo you're stinky yo
put it on your face
my God it's gonna be a first night out on the town
that's fun nice runs you have static shock
that's exactly what I was thinking oh
look at her brain her powers to life she's
like a cooler Miss Marvel yeah totally yeah
ah what the hell no Powerpuff
girl shut up you shut up
shut up buzz off Powerpuff come on we need to
get the rest imagine what I can do to those
dumb masks you're wearing oh damn oh my God
just the weight of that you're gonna leave
them squirming like turtles on their backs don't
come any closer don't worry how did you get there
so fast Adam and Betsy Wilkins are not your real
parents I'm adopted man that would explain a lot
my name is Dr Elias brandyworth I was the
assistant director of the pentagon's Department
of superhuman research research you eat out of
dumpsters yeah just stay off the grid to protect
you you were one of my projects cement now give
him some food Samantha all right he's giving you
valuable information you're crazy I'm leaving you
could see molecules turn paper into stone feel the
chemical composition of the world in your bones
he knows what he's talking about make me a nice
steak dinner out of some leaves yeah please can
you make some cash for me please I'm so hungry
then why come find me now the military thinks
you're dead if they discover you're not they'll
come for you yeah shut this [__] down stop using
them no I I can do things that matter I can help
people I'm begging you not to conceal don't feel
what's that noise what noise you have to go it's
already begun do not use your powers go even if
the military comes for you don't defend yourself
father and I have done everything for
you sent you to a special school look
the other way with these odd little
habits of yours I hate her parents
just be normal that's not what I said I love
you Samantha I do but I wish you'd try harder
sometimes great parenting guys I feel like
they they so Overlook just the caliber of
Genius that she is every parent we've killed
to have a child this morning we sent a drone
out after our sensors got paid guaranteed and
not become a prostitute down the road you know
I don't care about science you care about
industrial work playing into the
patriarchy stay in your your lane girl
are we closed have you seen him are you sure he
isn't here oh yes I look twice he's not here he's
he's by the dumpsters did he not tell you
look behind your local Applebee's be right
there way to not use your powers good job you
listen great you I'm gonna go way up in the
sky you understood the assignment clearly nice
soul patch bro makes your face extra punchable
get out of my way kid cut his head off once you
give that all back and sit down nicely and wait
for the police the names kill cannon not gets
beat up by little girls cam have you seen this
guy before he seems familiar right I'll know
on my re-watch what the hell kick his ass
we can just change his Cannon to something else
kill him you should literally never
have to throw a punch ever she could
just change his gun yeah yeah exactly
you're just not made for this great job
whoa whoa Samantha man did you get more
disheveled bro how did you show up told
you to be by the trash cans what you don't
even take a day off on your birthday how do
you know it's my birthday my parents didn't
even remember damn those parents are worthy
you have a super genius and you don't appreciate
her that's cool treat you a burger for some
answers oh thank God it's been waiting for she's
buying him a burger just make him a burger she was
a valued colleague she volunteered her pregnancy
for an experimental procedure oh interesting we
manipulated her amniotic fluid induced controlled
mutational change and I was making a terrible
mistake that's all she would have wanted for you
a normal life I like this scientist character
yeah too bad he's definitely gonna die a hundred
percent I'm wearing a mask I'm using a fake name
I'm apparently a government-designed super weapon
I'll be fine now how is the government still not
after you in present day that's what I want to
know I'm just going to wipe out this operation
former perimeter or something
what get the hell out of here
dope sauce
oh you're nasty
I kind of got a little something
hanging out your your face there
kurosi gross gross gross oh melty I have to
speak for our siblings they've never been out
of their tanks long enough to learn to talk our
siblings it's kind of tragic phase two phase three
Base Four phase five less successful than the
last but all one big happy family they're your
siblings oh so like Weapon X but like worse
or like 11 from stranger things yeah yeah
guys there's the blood there's
that Invincible violence
how did she become such a good fighter right
certainly she's been no more crime than
we were saying solving fighting more crime
this action is great
what disturbing body horror
would that phase two guy oh
you can't like change their molecules
and stuff too you can't heal them
we are reaching Man of Steel territory
oh you can't heal your own wounds
sweet
cool very cool thank you
our cave again
let's go iron Eve
oh God damn
so creative it's like Miss Marvel and Green
Lantern in one I was just saying the same thing
oh my God I mean it's so envious
what cool choreography
ah Man of Steel Man of Steel
you're making it worse you're just making it worse
there's a family in there nice hell yeah
that's the Man of Steel I'm looking for Heroic
side of making sure to protect the people
wouldn't that have been nice then why didn't keep
trying to attack her you started this Randy worth
he's not our family we're the best they could
make without him you should get Brandon worth
involved all we hear is how perfect you are
and how perfect we are that's not her fault
ouch why don't you like subdue them and just
like try to talk to him for a second laughs
oh brandyworth
you actually like this monster good
oh the impact of that still could have that didn't
save him he's old I think oh it did
thank you still not making out of
it prevent you from altering living tissue
break past your subconscious barrier ah look at
me yeah hey body horror is so disturbing oh my God
oh
I wish everything was different for us sure
yeah Samantha we have Samantha Brandy was
what a treat son of a [__] son
of a stash it's time to bring it
all down break past your subconscious
barrier let him go and we are playing
all right guys come on but now that I
have Brenda with his research partner
isn't needed anymore are you sure do it what
it's like a mom who who is that where do you think
all your brothers and sisters came from oh [__]
ah good old mom oh God technically alive we didn't
get her back up and running in time to save her
from mess and bring it get out my face bro come
on now you monster nah man don't freaking die
oh no the mom heal her this poor woman
oh my gosh it's been through so much
oh great it's getting off camera
death ray what the hell so lame
you were murdered
Scarlet witchton right I could
rearrange yourselves to make you
whole new people from the monsters she's
Dr Manhattan okay cool I am Samantha
and remember who I am
happened she broke free and prosper limits
but it wasn't her perspective since
they've done I was locked into her
perspective the whole time yeah
what where am I well a bit farther
oh she actually took a Kinder path to it huh yeah
oh God and where have you been Adam wait don't
stick up for her [__] a you couldn't even call
get that stick out your ass give me my cake wow
laughs
that's sad oh that's really sad please please come
out happy birthday let's try again that's so sad
only one I've got I get it man you gotta settle
for what you got I got jabby KOA on the internet
it's all going to be okay I promise
wow wow I thought they were gonna like go to
the par where we catch up to her age right I
thought they're gonna go present day all this
oh oh we're doing it yes um you're home early
yeah light day Dad look I'm gonna be duct tape
man that boy is never getting his powers is he
don't ask me you're the superhero space alien but
even if he doesn't I will love him just as much
no I won't you're just my pet I don't even love
you oh that Sinister look what are you so mad for
she needs to make sure his
son gets Powers oh right right
wow wow she's conflicted man wow the range
of emotion that man's face I know JK Simmons
performed that well with no dialogue right
there yeah man the animated the show JK said
all right man all right oh what a great time
to return to the world of invincible I really
enjoyed that I enjoyed that a lot I enjoyed that
a lot Aaron what did you think laid your thoughts
down later honest thoughts down about what you
liked what you didn't like as I get readjusted
here shake it out let's get readjusted here all
right what'd you like oh man I liked it all I
did not expect this to be a prequel if I didn't
watch any trailers or anything going into this
it said the first sentence is in this special
prequel episode you'd go in blinds you said
this is an in-betweekual like you knew what
you were talking about I mean prior to today
prior to the moments we sat down I had no clue
but yeah I thought it was really effective in us
really getting to see behind the scenes of what
our childhood is like gonna get more informed I
wonder if they did this because we're gonna see
a lot more of that backstory kind of continue
to the present day of season two sure so we
can kind of like really get invested with her
and it's they made this something that's like
non-essential at least from what we know so
far but I think it's going to add a lot of flavor
and uh peppering into the season uh hopefully it
plays back into it but yeah I thought the stuff
with um her find her found family or the people
she would choose to be really compelling you know
like she had a really shitty life and that kind of
that really sucks but I think
that yeah I think we got to see
what makes her her and the fact that you know she
cares so much and it's like she's this girl that
has these powers that wants to help people but
also kind of doesn't know who she is but she's
like way smarter than everyone else around her we
don't feel like she fed in and she finally at the
end found people that were of her kin you know and
I think that was very very cool and cool cool yeah
but yeah I thought the action was really good I
thought the music was really good um it made me
miss invincible and kind of remember what the show
is really about you know it balances that action
with the heart and it succeeds well at what it
does I think from a marketing standpoint which
is not the first thing I expected to talk about
I think from a marketing standpoint it's actually
kind of Genius because it takes place before
season one and other than uh the stuff with Omni
man it's not really trying to do these attempts
to you know fill in like specif like yes they were
always alluding to uh Adam Eve's backstory and and
then we saw that you know I think an invincible
season one she ends up running away from from her
home she did yeah yeah but it's what happens right
but this still can serve as a this like this
this perfectly segues you into doing a re-watch
yeah you know what I mean because it's been a few
years so people odds are there's probably gonna
be a lot of people who are gonna have to re-watch
they said they released this a few months before
season two comes out so it is a great way to
encourage people to go oh actually this is a an
awesome segue into going back into re-watching uh
season one and then we can watch season two when
it comes out I think that was like really smart
and I I really thought this was great because you
know prior to I liked I remember liking Adam Eve
but I mean at least for I think a lot of people
she was you know the main talk was always like
Market on me man right right and then I I know
that a lot of people really loved her uh but
the main thing that people when you look back
on Invincible is those two characters so with her
and knowing about the special I didn't know about
it until you texted me uh saying there's a new
special and I was like yeah we should watch it
and I was like yeah I'm interested because it's
Invincible but I I'm not like hyper curious about
it but this certainly quickly instilled of
vast appreciation for her character that I
don't quite recall having prior that makes me
excited to do the re-watch so that way I'm all
this knowledge and emotional Association is now
going to be applied when watching that Journey
because here what was neat was that it wasn't
like Ultra gory and it didn't exactly you know
Break The Rules or break the boundaries
in the way how you know the first season
of invincible did in a lot of ways it was a
darker Bolder and more experimental version of a
of an origin story yeah you know like and for for
the most part I was like oh this is about like a
the origin story by the numbers as you might
expect it to go when you just look at the
outline of stuff like the death of the scientist
was predictable and the way she was discovering
her powers and whatnot and and the Wonder and
then saving people and then towards like the last
um 10 to 15 minutes of this is when I thought
like oh they developed a really unique wrap
around for it I'm not saying it wasn't unique in
original throughout like they were peppering in
those unique original elements consistently you
know and it had a bit of that stranger things
tone that we were talking about and I appreciated
also to the the ability to do a lot with a little
where you don't really spend too much time with
these brothers but when they're there it's really
effective and you could feel the torture that
they went through you know uh the the anguish
that they there's a word for doing a lot with a
little and I can't quite pull it right now but
I remember writing it down and I don't know but
uh what the hell is it laconic is that the word
I think it's laconic laconic you would know you
looked the word up I don't know I've been doing
a lot with a little huh like um because it's
it's it it didn't I didn't leave this going
this should have been longer no no I think it
used its run time very well it was an hour long
it's like 50 something like 52 minutes or so
50 something 52 minutes I went by fast yeah
there was very well there are a couple things
that I do wish that they did Implement though
like in the end I didn't walk away going I wish
this was longer I think of course with a longer
run if it's like an hour and a half probably
would have been in tears by the end with the
way how some of the stuff played out could have
had more Breathing Room in certain elements of
course of course it did I think though again I'm
thinking about the marketing side of it that I
don't think as many people would tune in for an
hour and a half of course there are those people
I'm just saying I don't feel like most people you
think you're gonna get more people to tune in for
a 52 minute one that just feels like a regular
episode versus in like an hour and a half special
um but yeah like her her ability to use the
powers I think would have been kind of a cool
part of the origins hail to explore I actually
got good at fighting because she became like
incredibly good at fighting is that just part
of her skill set maybe I mean she she learned
she's learned a lot really quickly um yes yeah man
I feel like that's like a common like superhero
Trope though they learn really quickly without
doing much training so I think legitimately yeah
except that as like part of the conceit of the
story yeah yeah now I was able to get on board
with it but I I think that is something that still
would have helped just enhance it myself really
what it is is like there are things that just if
it was longer it could have just enhanced it yeah
you know it's always good to have more time to
flesh things out you know I think that it achieved
what it set out to do from the very beginning
that I think like even like the seeds of what
this thing had uh had set up you see through from
what they've [__] it's been two years but when
I remember of invincible like this whole thing
of like finding a place to belong into and like
her not feeling comfortable within her family and
she she had this family that she discovered very
late in the game when she got her powers but then
like within the show the proper show proper she
has this found family of like the superhero team
the Guardians and then she has some work she found
a sense of a friendship sense of kinship and I
think that's kind of been her journey through this
whole thing like realizing her own potential in
addition to realizing where she kind of fits into
things what I didn't okay if there's something I
didn't really like about the execution of this is
it's the it's the uh the parents I get your I
guess there's no Nuance really exactly that's
the exact word there's no Nuance the mom is like
you know I'm disciplining you know I'm sorry what
happened to you uh Matt oh what happened to
you and the dad's always like you're a [__]
it's the constantly them there's and I get
it you're not supposed to be likable they're
emotionally abusive uh I I understand
the intention I do think the execution
though even even in like a domestically violent
situation it can be they're gonna be Nuance to
to the levels of why they treat them the
way why they treat her the way they do or
you know seeing that other seeing that there
might be more of a conflict of why she does
ultimately still chew let's just goes through
like the territor's like Yeah The Experience is
murder and crazy violence like she's already at a
point like you can go but she's just a child and
you know she's got these emotional attachments
and stuff and I'm like at the same time though
she's she's got a significantly more experiences
than your average child and I could totally see
her like why did you go off on her own way
earlier than where she goes off on the show
um because there is no there's nothing here to
make me go I can see though as tough as her dad is
I also see why she loves her dad yeah especially
knowing that she's adopted by them you know like
I and I got none of those Shades other than
other than the Montage when she's a child of
like hey look we're getting along but as far as
their actual relationship goes I really do think
it lacked um like it's like I don't even call like
a single scene it didn't take anything big either
you could have had something like really small
like maybe her dad like going to knock on her door
but like walking away or something or like feeling
like a they sort of like a little bit of a sense
of shame but yeah it would have gotten more and
private though yeah in private exactly like not
so necessarily she had to see but yeah I'm trying
can't remember if there's any Nuance within the
parent characters within the the actual show
but I think it definitely needed some for sure
because you know I either want her to like get
entirely out of that situation or you know maybe
her parents come to some sense of of clarity or
some sense of light realizing like they've been so
shitty to their daughter you know like maybe they
can impair their relationship but I take it that's
probably not what's going to happen but yeah
something else I would like to see is like a more
connected point to where we are in the show like
a glimmer of hope that she does find like a sense
of community and finds a sense of of uh promise or
hope beyond the scenario which you just came into
you know like maybe she meets some of the heroes
that she's on a team with you're gonna meet her
in episode two of invincible she's already part
of the team I was like okay I would have liked to
see like some sort of how she became part of the
because there's a teen what I forgot the name of
it the teen team or something like that yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah also why she went from like
wearing a mask to not wearing a mask I didn't
get that either I should have learned that and
how she and how she met her who is her boyfriend
uh Rex I think Rex yeah yeah I mean we I guess
we don't really need to see all that I think it
was really cool to actually keep it I feel like
it would be cool like a part two of the special
if anything because I think what they decided to
focus on for this specific chapter of her life is
is really compelling stuff like even when we were
talking about stranger things the scientists is
like a nicer flip on Dr Brenner yeah you know oh
he was a scientist like oh I actually messed up
here I'm sorry I didn't even look after you right
instead of just trying to uh hone in on what you
are and make you a an awesome weapon yeah you know
that I sickly love at the same time I like the way
they I like their relation I like that character
um and I liked how they kept everything in the
perspective and also the potential like oh maybe
maybe this is someone who can help in the fight
against because in season one when it ended it
was a Seth Rogen character and he was saying
that more of omnimance people are coming yeah
yeah yeah the the vulture might something like
that Victor victory yeah and then yeah Victory
Boulevard yeah the sweet sweet victory yes uh
yeah they're coming and you see how oh maybe
she does but then again everyone seems like they
have potential but no I mean she's got this like
because they do have that tease about if she can
unlock what's in that subconscious she might have
the ability to actually rival some of the power
sets here yeah Lantern and Miss Marvel on the
one and and uh Dr Manhattan and Dr Manhattan yeah
yeah so wait did she go to that Supernova state
in the show proper I can't remember no idea okay
because I think it's interesting if she did or
if she hasn't yet that could be a potential tease
for things to come that we haven't seen just yet
I imagine they were the entire comic book is done
neither of us have read the comics we don't know
what what is to come so please don't spoil it but
um yeah yeah we gotta like not read the comments
yeah but comment and leave your thoughts down
below because it helps the video out but yeah
yeah yeah I'm curious I'm curious but don't tell
me if this is in the comics or not or there's
something strictly written for the show as like
a little additional uh thing to add flavor into
uh what we're about to watch in season two yeah
I thought it was interesting because I from the
poster or from like the thumbnail it made it seem
like it was going to start with her childhood or
her like Origins and then like lead into whatever
season two to tease but this was entirely took
place in the past so theoretically you could just
watch this prior to starting Invincible exactly
and just like go in that's exactly yeah I mean
no I mean it's just the thing when you when you
get to her and Invincible it it it informs you
at the background you just don't see how some
of these relationships started but it informs you
of it yeah yeah see and this this is giving you a
backstory that they only tease about being born in
a lab and stuff like that or scientist experiment
uh but as far as the story itself I thought it was
paced really well and there's it's tragic I love
how tragic it is that is my that's the thing
that truly separates in it as well from just
your typical origin story is just how freaking
Bleak it gets you know and as some stuff feels
a bit rushed over like oh the mom returning uh
being in that chamber like again in a longer run
time would have helped enhance these moments and
could have brought to things like I'm freaking
crying right now is that that could have that
could have had room for some truly compelling
moments but I had a stronger Punch Yeah yeah
a lot of things could have uh in that regard
but I can't say like I was disappointed by the
end and the and I'm not just being nice about
it like I'd be honest with you if I was like
man what the [__] but the the but that the
whole storyline I think was uh was truly something
like so messed up and and I like how messed up it
ended like sometimes origin sales they do end on
a note that has a and some type of all those loss
that really helps to find the characters sure
but this is just like knockout after knockout
to This Girl's Life or identity and then coming
to a home where it doesn't even end on a cliche
note of oh but I have my family here like no
these guys are messed up you know like this
does not feel like home to her so it just ends on
the darkest of notes and then you cut to Mark's
life which looks like the perfect family but no
that's actually the truly Sinister one so I like
the mirroring of that yeah you know so yeah I
thought it was great man I thought it was great
yeah yeah maybe you couldn't watch this before
because like the Omni man told emotional range
and you go and like what's that about that's like
it's like it's like 30 seconds but you could just
be like what does that mean what's the tease of
what yeah but it doesn't give any exact detail or
anything yeah yeah alrighty guys well what did you
think about this special leave your thoughts down
below keep a lookout for when we cover Invincible
season two um subscribe follow Aaron you could
catch us on patreon and we will talk with you all
soon ladies and gentlemen thank you for being here
thank you